stéphane audran si vous êtes venus
chercher un bon bol d'air à marseille et
bien voilà vous êtes servant je les
trouvais s'émerveiller peut-être un peu
trop non non non non non non rien à
envier à trouver la méditerranée et puis
on vous offre un peu la bretagne
oui c'est les deux à la fois c'est
fantastique de toute façon pour une
parisienne à tout est mieux que park
pour moi vraiment et bien d'autres actes
dont tacle de toute manière vous êtes
venu non pas nous parler du beau temps
ou de l'appli vous êtes venu nous parler
des durs à cuire
oui alors on vous écoute et bien j'ai
tourné ce film en décembre dans un
merveilleux château
avec jacques pinoteau et j'avais pour
partenaire roger pierre jean poiret et
michel serrault mireille darc et hubert
deschamps qui étaient de très joyeux
compagnons c'est à dire qu'on sait pas
embêté rice il ya un personnage ou
plutôt un acteur que vous n'avez pas
cité encore j'ai oublié le présent la
long qui est claude chabrol qui
exceptionnellement interprète un
personnage de psychiatres on a
l'impression quelques fois que claude
chabrol dans son personnage est un peu
scrutateurs à travers ses lunettes c'est
bien compréhensible qu'ils vous
regardent et qui vous suit vous dans
votre personnage de très près il me
surveillait
oui parce que pour ne rien vous cacher
pour ne rien vous cacher
claude chabrol et les poules heureux
époux de madame stéphane audran voilà et
leur papa d'un enfant est papa d'un beau
but
on peut en parler de ce dommage je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une grande date
pour lui c'est son anniversaire il a un
nom et sa môman des pourquoi je suis
loin de lui
c'est gentil pour nous si ce n'est pas
un gentil poli parlons tout de même de
ces durs à cuire vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure que vous êtes forte amusé
pendant le tournage
oui pourquoi et parce que j'avais des
partenaires qui me faisait rire tout le
temps et que c'est extraordinaire de
tourner dans ces conditions une autre
remarque en ce qui vous concerne
stéphane audran dans landru d'un certain
monsieur claude chabrol
vous étiez à peu près est l'unique
rescapée celle qui ne passait pas dans
la cuisinière
ah oui et puis dans ce film qui est
cornélien par certains côtés puisque les
personnages meurent les uns après les
autres
vous êtes encore rescapés oui
bénédiction je m'arrange toujours pour
terminer les films ses pinceaux oui oui
c'est pas bête comme ça on air du bout
d'un bout à l'autre du film est bien
stéphane audran puisque vous nous
confirmer que vous êtes fort tamisée
dans ce film en compagnie de vos petits
camarades
on peut imaginer que c'est une promesse
que vous faites aux spectateurs de leur
communiquer un peu c'est un oui j'espère
qu'ils s'amuseront bienveillance il
on en accepte l'auguré remercie
[Musique]